Honestly, I don't want to offend our C++ listeners, but the best community is the array community. It's, you know, they think the right way, you know. You know, Phineas here, he swims in the land of folds and scans. You know, we just like, we spend a little bit of time there because we work at NVIDIA and it's important to us. But like C++ programmers, they're like a scan? What's that? It's like a partial sum, you know. Not everybody. The listeners of this podcast probably know. But most of the C++ devs they're like, a scan? What's that? It's like a partial sum, you know? Not everybody. The listeners of this podcast probably know.
老实说，我不想冒犯我们的 C++ 听众，但最好的社区是数组社区。他们思考问题的方式是对的。Phineas 在这里，他沉浸在折叠（fold）和扫描（scan）的世界里。我们只是花了一点时间在那里，因为我们在 NVIDIA 工作，这对我们很重要。但像 C++ 程序员，他们会问：扫描？那是什么？就像部分和（partial sum），你知道的。并不是所有人，这个播客的听众可能知道。但大多数 C++ 开发人员会问：扫描？那是什么？就像部分和，你知道的。并不是所有人，这个播客的听众可能知道。
But most of the C++ devs out there, you know, they're still catching up on... One potato, two potato. Yeah, one potato, two potato. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 176 recorded on march 6 2024 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we chat about the algorithms from the q language prior deltas and more with phineas porter over dinner i don't know i don't have a plan, Connor. But I've had a revelation, and the people need to know about the revelation. Do you want to do the introduction? This is just like when we were doing the Slovenia 2023 road trip, and every time he'd start recording, he'd be like,
但大多数 C++ 开发人员，他们还在赶进度……一个土豆，两个土豆。是的，一个土豆，两个土豆。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 176 期，录制于 2024 年 3 月 6 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，在晚餐时与 Phineas Porter 聊聊 Q 语言中的算法、prior、deltas 等等。我不知道，我没有计划，Connor。但我有一个启示，人们需要知道这个启示。你想做介绍吗？这就像我们进行 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行时一样，每次他开始录音，他就会说：
all right, recording again. And I'd be like, no, Bryce, we have to do the intro we are at francia this isn't getting picked up this isn't getting picked up we got one mic now and it's tiny uh we're at the francia vegan cafe a place that ramona does not like uh that bry Bryce just said she's never even been here. She's not a big fan of vegan food. She's Polish, so she likes her meat and potatoes. And Bryce's cholesterol is too high, so he's not allowed meat.
好了，又在录音了。我会说，不，Bryce，我们必须做介绍，我们在 Francia，这录不进去，这录不进去。我们现在只有一个麦克风，而且很小。我们在 Francia 素食咖啡馆，Ramona 不喜欢这个地方。Bryce 刚说她从来没来过这里。她不太喜欢素食。她是波兰人，所以她喜欢肉和土豆。而且 Bryce 的胆固醇太高了，所以他不被允许吃肉。
I myself did go to Shake Shack for lunch and got two double hamburgers with bacon. I calculated the calories. It was 1,280 or something. It was worth every calorie. Anyways, we're here at a cafe. It's not just me and Bryce. We're with a never-before-guest on ADSP the podcast.
我自己午餐去了 Shake Shack，吃了两个双层培根汉堡。我计算了卡路里，大约是 1280 卡。每一卡路里都值了。总之，我们在一家咖啡馆。不只是我和 Bryce。我们还有一位从未上过 ADSP 播客的嘉宾。
And honestly, probably he should be on a Raycast, not ADSP the podcast. We have enough incentive for him to be on the podcast. I mean, he hasn't said no at this point. You've got to keep your voice down. You've got to keep your voice down. You've got to keep your voice down. We had some noise complaints earlier, and... I got PTSD from when this just happened right now. Anyways, no, we're going to let Phineas introduce him.
老实说，他可能应该上 ArrayCast，而不是 ADSP 播客。我们有足够的理由让他上这个播客。我的意思是，到目前为止他还没说不。你得小声点。你得小声点。你得小声点。我们之前收到了一些噪音投诉，而且……我刚才经历了创伤后应激障碍。总之，不，我们要让 Phineas 自我介绍。
Connor doesn't seem to understand how consent works. You have to ask people. You can't just assume that a non-response means yes. Phineas, do you want to be on our podcast? Sounds good. Also, T, I mean, he hasn't, I don't, have you, you haven't been mentioned by name on ADSP, the podcast. You probably haven't been mentioned, what do you call it? Synonymously.
Connor 似乎不明白同意是怎么回事。你必须询问别人。你不能仅仅假设没有回应就意味着同意。Phineas，你想上我们的播客吗？听起来不错。还有，T，我的意思是，他还没有，我不知道，你，你还没有在 ADSP 播客上被点名。你可能还没被提到，你怎么说来着？同义地。
Like, yeah, without, it? Synonymously. Yeah, synonymously. And that was the same thing on a Raycast, but then at some point you did get mentioned by name, because I think I asked you if it was okay. So I have subtly asked for consent. Anyways, I'm going to hand it back to Bryce. We just finished dinner. There's some surprise event happening later. Nobody knows what's happening.
就像，是的，没有它？同义地。是的，同义地。在 ArrayCast 上也是一样，但后来你在某个时候确实被点名了，因为我想我问过你是否可以。所以我已经委婉地征求了同意。总之，我要把它交回给 Bryce。我们刚吃完晚饭。稍后会有一个惊喜活动。没人知道会发生什么。
And Franchio, it was pretty delicious. It was pretty delicious. It's quite charged okay good back to bryce so uh after we had our revelation earlier today that um that reduced by key is implemented in terms of scan in cub in terms of scan by key in cub which is even worse um i know i we've spent a lot of time in this pot i had a revelation and we've spent a lot of time in this podcast talking about how like everything's implemented in terms of you know a couple of primitive algorithms but like more and more it's just everything is implemented in terms of scan and i realized that all of the CUB algorithms, I think, in some way, shape, and form
Franchio，非常美味。非常美味。它相当充实，好的，回到 Bryce。所以，在我们今天早些时候有了那个启示之后，即 CUB 中的 reduce-by-key 是用 scan 实现的，用 CUB 中的 scan-by-key 实现的，这更糟糕。我知道，我们在这个播客里花了很多时间，我有一个启示，我们花了很多时间在这个播客里谈论一切是如何用几个原始算法实现的，但越来越多地，一切都只是用 scan 实现的，我意识到所有的 CUB 算法，我想，以某种形式
use scan other than just straight reduce and for. Histogram, I think, uses scan. The sorts definitely uses scan. Scan uses scan. All the run length encoding, run length decoding
都使用 scan，除了直接的 reduce 和 for。Histogram，我想，使用了 scan。Sorts 肯定使用了 scan。Scan 使用了 scan。所有的游程编码（run length encoding）、游程解码
uses scan. What other algorithms are in Cub? Copy if uses scan. Like they're all just fancy scans is what I'm saying. Everything is just a fancy scan. First of all, listeners, I'm disappointed. This is what we turned the mic on in the middle of dinner for. This is a little bit disappointing.
都使用 scan。Cub 里还有什么其他算法？Copy-if 使用了 scan。我的意思是，它们都只是花哨的 scan。首先，听众们，我很失望。这就是我们在晚餐中间打开麦克风的原因。这有点令人失望。
Yes, thank you very much. It was delicious. Yeah, that's true. We did have ice cream last night. Anyways, disappointed that this is what we turned the mic on. We're not giving it back to you yet. I've got the power. But transforms? Transforms are not giving it back to you yet. I've got the power. But transforms?
是的，非常感谢。它很美味。是的，那是真的。我们昨晚确实吃了冰淇淋。总之，很失望我们打开麦克风就是为了这个。我们还没打算把它交还给你。我有控制权。但是 transforms？Transforms 还没打算把它交还给你。我有控制权。但是 transforms？
Transforms are not implemented in terms of the scan. Should we hand it over to Phineas? Also, Phineas, in case we don't let him say anything, because I feel like Bryce is not going to let him, we will make sure we put a link. That's cool. We will put a link to a talk he was featured in. Nick Cyrus gave a talk at KXCon 2023.
Transforms 不是用 scan 实现的。我们应该把它交给 Phineas 吗？还有，Phineas，万一我们不让他说话，因为我觉得 Bryce 不会让他说的，我们会确保放一个链接。那很酷。我们会放一个他参与的演讲的链接。Nick Cyrus 在 KXCon 2023 上做了一个演讲。
It was fantastic. You also gave a talk. What am I even talking about? I was going to say, I remember it from the Q Gods. He's a Q God, but he also gave a fantastic talk himself. Both will be linked. Hopefully, Phineas will get to say something, but Bryce is throwing a tantrum across the table
非常精彩。你也做了一个演讲。我到底在说什么？我本来想说，我从 Q 之神那里记得它。他是 Q 之神，但他自己也做了一个精彩的演讲。两者都会有链接。希望 Phineas 能说点什么，但 Bryce 在桌子对面发脾气
because I'm hoarding the mic. I don't even remember what I was going to say. What was I going to say? What were we talking about? Oh, yeah. I'm talking about solely Cub algorithms, which are like the underlying low-level primitives. And in Cub's world, like a transform and a 4H are both just 4.
因为我霸占了麦克风。我甚至不记得我要说什么了。我要说什么？我们在谈论什么？哦，对了。我是在谈论纯粹的 Cub 算法，它们就像底层的低级原语。在 Cub 的世界里，transform 和 for-each 都只是 for。
Like Cub has a device 4, and both are just forms of that. Anyways, I'll let other people talk now. I don't have anything to say. Should we interview Phineas? Let's interview Phineas. Probably the episode of Which is the Mother Algorithm. Oh, yeah. Wait, you want to discuss that again?
Cub 有一个 device for，两者都只是它的形式。总之，我现在让别人说话。我没什么可说的。我们应该采访 Phineas 吗？让我们采访 Phineas。可能是关于“哪个是母算法”的那一集。哦，对了。等等，你想再讨论一次吗？
No, you should just point out this was already the claim. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. One of your guests already claimed this. We already... I think you actually said claim. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. One of your guests already claimed this. We already... I think you actually said this. Yeah, I probably did. Just talking to this thing. I think Bryce said that, actually, on an earlier episode,
不，你应该指出这已经是之前的观点了。哦，是的，是的，是的。你的一位嘉宾已经声称过这一点了。我们已经……我想你实际上说了声称。哦，是的，是的，是的。你的一位嘉宾已经声称过这一点了。我们已经……我想你实际上说了这个。是的，我可能说了。只是对着这个东西说话。我想 Bryce 实际上在之前的一集里说过，
that scan was the ultimate algorithm, because you can implement everything as a scan. Or maybe he claimed that reduce was a scan, because if you just keep enough state around, your reduce can also work as a scan, technically. So it really reduces every algorithm. Yeah.
scan 是终极算法，因为你可以把一切都实现为 scan。或者也许他声称 reduce 是一个 scan，因为如果你保持足够的状态，你的 reduce 在技术上也可以作为 scan 工作。所以它确实简化了每一个算法。是的。
Yeah, I believe that. So there is all this reduces. I mean, yeah, we will link to ADSP episode, what was it? I don't know. 120? That's a guess.
是的，我相信这一点。所以这就是所有的 reduces。我的意思是，是的，我们会链接到 ADSP 的那一集，是哪一集？我不知道。120？这是一个猜测。
We'll see how, I'll look it up after, but Ben was on. I'm going to look it up right now. Ben Dean was on the episode. Tristan Brindles was on the episode. All right, folks. As you might be able to tell, Bryce was in charge of the audio. He brought his
我们会看看，我稍后会查一下，但 Ben 在那一集。我现在就查一下。Ben Dean 在那一集。Tristan Brindles 在那一集。好了，各位。正如你们可能看出来的，Bryce 负责音频。他带了自己的
own lapel Rode microphone. Questionable, questionable audio quality. And somehow, he silenced it or muted the mic for a minute and a half here. So you're going to miss a minute and a half of conversation. We apologize. I apologize on behalf of Bryce. Back to the conversation. Talk about whether prior should keep the first element or not. Yes.
Rode 领夹麦克风。音频质量值得怀疑，值得怀疑。不知何故，他在这里把麦克风静音了一分半钟。所以你们会错过一分半钟的对话。我们道歉。我代表 Bryce 道歉。回到对话。谈谈 prior 是否应该保留第一个元素。是的。
Yeah. I mean, I think obviously prior should keep the first element. You can reconstruct the original list that way, and it makes all the lengths the same, so it's just very convenient for the shape. But Connor here thinks that you should drop the first element because it's not really part of the reduction. So, first of all, prior is the correct name for adjacent difference, and I've actually adopted the name prior in my own...
是的。我的意思是，我认为显然 prior 应该保留第一个元素。你可以通过这种方式重建原始列表，而且它使所有长度相同，所以对于形状来说非常方便。但 Connor 认为你应该丢弃第一个元素，因为它不是归约（reduction）的一部分。所以，首先，prior 是 adjacent difference 的正确名称，我实际上已经在我的……中采用了 prior 这个名称。
Sorry? Who wants to drop the first element? So Bryce... Sorry? Who wants to drop the first element? So Bryce has asked who wants to drop the first element. The answer is me. And the answer is we did. Because we added in C++23 a view called adjacent transform, which is the modern version of adjacent difference. And that does drop the first element.
抱歉？谁想丢弃第一个元素？所以 Bryce……抱歉？谁想丢弃第一个元素？所以 Bryce 问谁想丢弃第一个元素。答案是我。答案是我们做了。因为我们在 C++23 中添加了一个名为 adjacent transform 的视图，它是 adjacent difference 的现代版本。它确实丢弃了第一个元素。
If you don't drop the first element, what do you do? Keep the first element. You can reconstruct. So cumulative sums and deltas gives you the original list if you have the first element. Otherwise, you're missing a constant. It's like integrating a calculus. If you drop C, you don't have the C anymore. You're done. And this is brilliant because
如果你不丢弃第一个元素，你做什么？保留第一个元素。你可以重建。所以累积和（cumulative sums）和差分（deltas）如果你有第一个元素，就能给你原始列表。否则，你缺少一个常数。就像微积分中的积分。如果你丢弃了 C，你就没有 C 了。你完了。这很棒，因为
deltas... You just want to keep it just on its own? You just want to want to keep it just on its own? You just want to keep the first element just on its own? Return the len... you have an iterate... you have a container, it has n elements in it, and the first element is the same element as it was in the original list. But what if the type changes? This is the problem with typed languages. That's the problem.
deltas……你只是想把它单独保留？你只是想把它单独保留？你只是想把第一个元素单独保留？返回 len……你有一个迭代器……你有一个容器，它里面有 n 个元素，第一个元素和原始列表中的元素相同。但如果类型改变了怎么办？这就是类型化语言的问题。这就是问题所在。
That's the problem. So this is, that's exactly it. So adjacent difference has a constraint and because it copies that first element in order to maintain the circular round trip between partial sum, etc. Or like ratios and we'll give you back the original series. So if you take ratios between all the numbers, you know what the percent changes are, and then you can go back to the original list. This is like a very convenient feature to have around. When you do, a lot of times you're looking for like,
这就是问题所在。所以这就是，完全正确。所以 adjacent difference 有一个约束，因为它复制了第一个元素，以便维持部分和等之间的循环往复。或者像比率（ratios），我们会给你返回原始序列。所以如果你取所有数字之间的比率，你就知道百分比变化是多少，然后你就可以回到原始列表。这是一个非常方便的功能。当你做的时候，很多时候你在寻找像，
I want to find all the cases where something big happened, and then I want the actual numbers. I don't have to keep around two lists around with me the whole time, I just keep around the one element and then come back. Bryce is ordering his dessert here. I will have the chocolate fudge cake. I will have the tiramisu.
我想找到所有发生重大情况的案例，然后我想要实际的数字。我不必一直带着两个列表，我只需要保留一个元素，然后回来。Bryce 在这里点甜点。我要巧克力软糖蛋糕。我要提拉米苏。
Connor? Okay. Connor being boring. Where were we? I've had the two Shake Shack burgers. Did you have a Shake Shack? I don't like shakes. Bryce asked me. You don't like shakes?
Connor？好的。Connor 很无聊。我们刚才说到哪了？我吃了两个 Shake Shack 汉堡。你吃 Shake Shack 了吗？我不喜欢奶昔。Bryce 问我。你不喜欢奶昔？
What is wrong with you? This thing has auto gain. It's supposed to be idiot proof. I had two burgers at Shake Shack. Then I had lunch at a Thai place where I had a couple chicken wings and pad thai. Yeah, yeah. I told you I was meeting up with an acquaintance, Ashley, if you're listening.
你有什么毛病？这个东西有自动增益。它应该是傻瓜式的。我在 Shake Shack 吃了两个汉堡。然后我在一家泰国餐馆吃了午餐，吃了几个鸡翅和泰式炒河粉。是的，是的。我告诉过你我要去见一个熟人，Ashley，如果你在听的话。
And what? Ashley. She's another member from the KXQ community. Honestly, I don't want to offend our C++ listeners, but the best community is the array community. They think the right way. Phineas here, he swims in the land of folds and scans.
什么？Ashley。她是 KXQ 社区的另一位成员。老实说，我不想冒犯我们的 C++ 听众，但最好的社区是数组社区。他们思考问题的方式是对的。Phineas 在这里，他沉浸在折叠和扫描的世界里。
We just spend a little bit of time there because we work at NVIDIA and it's important to us, but C++ programmers, they're like, a scan? What's that? It's like a partial sum? Not everybody. The listeners of this podcast probably know. But most of the C++ devs out there, they're still catching up on it. Two potato type things.
我们只是花了一点时间在那里，因为我们在 NVIDIA 工作，这对我们很重要，但 C++ 程序员，他们会问：扫描？那是什么？就像部分和？并不是所有人。这个播客的听众可能知道。但大多数 C++ 开发人员，他们还在赶进度。两个土豆之类的事情。
Yeah, one potato, two potato. What's the resolution to the fire thing? How did you two resolve your differences? Oh, we didn't. Oh, Bryce. I asked, how did you two resolve your differences? And the answer is, I mean, I think we came to an agreement that... I think for type languages, it makes sense to be...
是的，一个土豆，两个土豆。关于那个火的事情的解决方案是什么？你们俩是怎么解决分歧的？哦，我们没有。哦，Bryce。我问，你们俩是怎么解决分歧的？答案是，我的意思是，我想我们达成了一个协议，即……我想对于类型语言，有意义的是……
You have to have at least two types, right? You need to be able to maintain the fact that, like, if you change types, you can't keep this first element. But, like I said, it's, like, much more memory efficient to, like, not keep around the original list if you can go back and forth between the two. And in Q and array languages, your first type can be different. You can end up with a heterogeneous list, right?
你必须至少有两种类型，对吧？你需要能够维持这样一个事实，即如果你改变类型，你就不能保留这个第一个元素。但正如我所说，如果你能在两者之间来回切换，不保留原始列表会更节省内存。在 Q 和数组语言中，你的第一个类型可以不同。你最终可以得到一个异构列表，对吧？
So you can't do that in type languages. And I think so what we ended up agreeing on is that prior and adjacent difference... What? I don't see a reason that you couldn't have a list and an iterator in C++ where the, well. You can create an iterator, but you can't create a container that has nice properties. What are you going to wrap it in? What are you going to wrap it in, like a std variant? Absolutely not.
所以你在类型语言中做不到这一点。我认为我们最终达成一致的是，prior 和 adjacent difference……什么？我不认为有什么理由在 C++ 中不能有一个列表和一个迭代器，其中，嗯。你可以创建一个迭代器，但你不能创建一个具有良好属性的容器。你要把它包装在什么里面？你要把它包装在像 std variant 里面吗？绝对不行。
So the point being is for convenience, adjacent difference and prior, especially in array languages that are dynamically typed, is very nice. However, if you want to design the perfect generic algorithm that you are able to implement all the different flavors of kind of deltas and adjacent difference or adjacent transform, you want the one that doesn't bundle that first type there. And then from there, you can kind of do everything you want. There's another solution.
所以重点是，为了方便起见，adjacent difference 和 prior，特别是在动态类型的数组语言中，非常好。然而，如果你想设计完美的通用算法，能够实现各种不同风格的差分或 adjacent difference 或 adjacent transform，你想要那个不捆绑第一个类型的算法。然后从那里，你可以做任何你想做的事。还有另一个解决方案。
So the other solution is that your function, the operator you're going to apply between all the adjacent elements should have a default-like type for that. Like identity value. If you have that, then the identity value can push it into the first element, into the correct identity type for the first element. So if you want to do a prior transform where you're bundling your prior with a binary operation, which is typically what you're doing, right? Prior and adjacent transform, they're higher order functions that take a binary operation. If your binary operation and your type form, what is it, a monad or a semigroup or whatever it is from category theory, that comes with an identity value.
所以另一个解决方案是，你的函数，即你将在所有相邻元素之间应用的运算符，应该有一个默认的类型。比如恒等值（identity value）。如果你有那个，那么恒等值就可以把它推入第一个元素，推入第一个元素的正确恒等类型中。所以如果你想做一个 prior transform，你把你的 prior 和一个二元运算捆绑在一起，这通常是你正在做的，对吧？Prior 和 adjacent transform，它们是接受二元运算的高阶函数。如果你的二元运算和你的类型形式，是什么，单子（monad）或半群（semigroup）或范畴论中的任何东西，它带有一个恒等值。
And so if you've got integers with plus, that identity value is going to be zero. And so you can just use that value as the first element. And then instead of ending up with n minus one elements, you end up with n. just use that value as the first element, and then instead of ending up with n minus 1 elements, you end up with n. And that's the other thing I haven't commented on, is the convenience thing about the way prior works is that, like, in array languages, you like to end up with equally lengthed arrays
所以如果你有带加法的整数，那个恒等值就是零。所以你可以直接用那个值作为第一个元素。然后你最终得到的不是 n 减 1 个元素，而是 n 个。直接用那个值作为第一个元素，然后你最终得到的不是 n 减 1 个元素，而是 n 个。这就是我还没评论的另一件事，关于 prior 工作方式的便利性是，在数组语言中，你喜欢得到等长的数组
because then your scalar operations work, and you don't end up having to jump through hoops. We care about that less in, like, a ranges-like library because it's a sequence. What about for zip? Does zip have laziness built in? I actually don't know how our zip works.
因为这样你的标量运算就能工作，你也不必费尽周折。我们在像 ranges 这样的库中对此不太在意，因为它是一个序列。Zip 怎么样？Zip 有内置的惰性吗？我实际上不知道我们的 zip 是怎么工作的。
Of course. Sorry, not laziness, like short-circuiting. Like if one length is different. It goes to whichever is the shortest. Yeah, yeah. And then there's equivalent algorithms. Right, so Phineas just asked, what about zip? I said something about laziness, but in my head I meant short-circuiting because in functional languages like Haskell and whatnot,
当然。抱歉，不是惰性，是短路（short-circuiting）。比如如果一个长度不同。它会取最短的那个。是的，是的。然后有等效的算法。对，所以 Phineas 刚才问，zip 怎么样？我说了一些关于惰性的东西，但在我脑子里我指的是短路，因为在像 Haskell 之类的函数式语言中，
they usually have two different algorithms, zip that short-circuits to whatever the shorter length is, and then they also have one called zip longest, which they have varying flavors. Sometimes you can give it, like, a default value to put in there. Sometimes it'll just fill it with, like, some Knoll or something like that. And we're going to hand it back to Bryce because he's had a couple slices of his cake, and I'm guessing we're going to get a review here.
它们通常有两种不同的算法，zip 会短路到较短的长度，然后它们还有一个叫 zip longest 的，它们有不同的变体。有时你可以给它一个默认值放进去。有时它只会用一些空值之类的东西填充它。我们要把它交回给 Bryce，因为他吃了两片蛋糕，我猜我们要得到一个评价。
It's a pretty good cake. I mean, it's hard to believe it's vegan. What do you have against vegans, Bryce? I literally brought us all. I don't have any problem with vegans. I literally brought us all to a vegan restaurant, and I'm trying to convert my meat-only girlfriend to at least sometimes enjoy a vegan meal. So I don't want to alarm anyone,
这蛋糕相当不错。我的意思是，很难相信它是纯素的。你对纯素食者有什么意见，Bryce？我简直把我们都带来了。我对纯素食者没有任何问题。我简直把我们都带到了一家纯素餐厅，我正试图让我只吃肉的女朋友至少有时能享受一顿纯素餐。所以我不想惊动任何人，
but my phone has 30% battery left, and we will need some percentage battery to navigate to various places and various things. So we've got to interview rapidly. I mean, anything we've talked about prior. I mean, I've got to say, too, prior. Actually, in my toy work project, which hopefully isn't a toy in the future, I used the name Prior because I think it's honestly better than Adjacent Transform. It's shorter.
但我的手机只剩 30% 的电量了，我们需要一些电量来导航到各个地方和各种事情。所以我们必须快速采访。我的意思是，我们谈论的任何关于 prior 的事情。我的意思是，我也得说，prior。实际上，在我的玩具工作项目中，希望将来不是玩具，我使用了 Prior 这个名字，因为我认为它老实说比 Adjacent Transform 更好。它更短。
I do love short names. I changed Deltas to Diffs to match NumPy a little bit more, which I actually think Diffs is a little bit too close to one other thing. But things are matching, quality matching. Yeah, yeah. So it's not – all right, I'm going to take a bite of this cake. I'm not going to identify it as a vegan cake. Cake is cake, folks.
我确实喜欢短名字。我把 Deltas 改成了 Diffs 以便更匹配 NumPy，我实际上认为 Diffs 有点太接近另一件事了。但事情正在匹配，质量匹配。是的，是的。所以它不是——好了，我要咬一口这个蛋糕。我不会把它标识为纯素蛋糕。蛋糕就是蛋糕，伙计们。
You know, we don't discriminate here over in Canada. I guess we're in America right now. Oh, that's not clear. But you should mention that I will be in Canada next week. Yeah, it's pretty crazy. Well, now I got a mouthful of cake. Oh, this cake is good. And I'm not a big tiramisu fan, you know.
你知道，我们在加拿大不歧视。我想我们现在在美国。哦，那不清楚。但你应该提到我下周会在加拿大。是的，这太疯狂了。好吧，现在我满嘴都是蛋糕。哦，这蛋糕真好吃。而且我不是提拉米苏的忠实粉丝，你知道。
It's too complicated. It's got... What do they call them? What are the sticks? The fingers? The lady fingers? The lady fingers, yeah. Don't get me wrong. I'll eat a tiramisu if... I love tiramisu. But yeah, Diff's deltas, prior. I mean, this actually probably is going to come out in like a month and a half from now
它太复杂了。它有……他们叫它们什么？那些棍子？手指？手指饼干？手指饼干，是的。别误会我。如果……我喜欢提拉米苏。但是的，Diffs deltas，prior。我的意思是，这实际上可能在一个半月后出来
because we've got so much content once again. But I will link to the episode of ArrayCast. We're going to be having on someone from KX. We initially were hoping to get Andrew Wilson from the KX Core team. I think he said no because he doesn't like us. Not because he doesn't like us. I'm just joking around, obviously. And then we're juggling a few people.
因为我们又有了这么多内容。但我会链接到 ArrayCast 的那一集。我们将邀请 KX 的某个人。我们最初希望邀请 KX 核心团队的 Andrew Wilson。我想他说不，因为他不喜欢我们。不是因为他不喜欢我们。我显然是在开玩笑。然后我们正在协调几个人。
Why did he say no? I don't know. Some people just... I think he has to speak at KXCon because he works for KX and they force him to but language people aren't necessarily the same people that want to get up in front of a crowd or get in front of a mic
他为什么说不？我不知道。有些人只是……我想他必须在 KXCon 上发言，因为他为 KX 工作，他们强迫他，但语言方面的人不一定是那些想站在人群面前或站在麦克风前的人
we're anomalies especially you although what were you saying earlier Connor stop referring to our podcast as a pod I was like what are you talking about it's such a large part of our life now I refer to our conversations as was that one on pod or off pod because I can't there's been so many conversations at this point I can't
我们是异常，尤其是你，虽然你刚才在说什么，Connor？别再把我们的播客称为 pod 了。我当时想，你在说什么？它现在是我们生活中如此重要的一部分，我把我们的对话称为那是 pod 上的还是 pod 下的，因为我不能，到目前为止已经有太多对话了，我不能
keep track I did sort of typically uh record uh Connor earlier today where we were just talking about some problem because I'm like this could be good podcast content and there are times when I really want to talk about something with Connor but I'll wait because I'm like well if we start talking about this it might be really good and then I would want to record it for the podcast that's what happened in Venice when when we were going to go on that walk I literally was like aha I have it and you were like stop talking and I was like I haven't even started talking you're like you were about to I mean that walk, I literally was like, aha, I have it. And you were like, stop talking. And I was like, I haven't even started talking. And you were like, you were about to. And you wouldn't let me start explaining myself until we were recording.
跟踪。我今天早些时候确实记录了 Connor，当时我们只是在谈论某个问题，因为我想这可能是很好的播客内容，有时我真的很想和 Connor 谈论某事，但我会等，因为我想，好吧，如果我们开始谈论这个，它可能真的很好，然后我会想把它录下来作为播客，这就是在威尼斯发生的事情，当我们打算去散步时，我简直说，啊哈，我有它了，你却说，别说了，我说我还没开始说，你说你正要说。我的意思是那次散步，我简直说，啊哈，我有它了。你却说，别说了。我说我还没开始说。你说你正要说。而且直到我们录音，你都不让我开始解释自己。
But you know what? For all the shit you give me about not contributing to the production values of this podcast, I do make sure we're recording the good content. Honestly, this is going to result in us at like 50. Like once our kids are, or I guess actually we're already in our 30s. So when we're 60, once our kids are like up in university, we're going to like get our own, you know, it won't even be Netflix at that point because GPTs will be so good,
但你知道吗？对于你给我关于不为这个播客的制作价值做出贡献的所有废话，我确实确保我们在录制好的内容。老实说，这将导致我们达到 50 岁。就像一旦我们的孩子，或者我想实际上我们已经 30 多岁了。所以当我们 60 岁时，一旦我们的孩子上大学了，我们将得到我们自己的，你知道，那时甚至不会是 Netflix，因为 GPT 会变得非常好，
we won't even call them that anymore. Everyone will be able to go make their own reality TV show. All we need to do is we'll need to put a couple rings up in the corners of our apartments and feed it some footage, and we'll be able to have our own, the ADSP, the reality TV show. And it'll be fantastic. We won't have to edit anything. It'll just know when Bryce says certain topics, it'll automatically filter it up. And then that one time it'll mess up and then we'll get canceled.
我们甚至不会再那样称呼它们了。每个人都将能够制作自己的真人秀节目。我们所需要做的就是，我们需要在公寓的角落里放几个环，并给它喂一些素材，我们就能够拥有我们自己的，ADSP，真人秀节目。而且它会很棒。我们不需要编辑任何东西。它只是知道当 Bryce 说某些话题时，它会自动过滤它。然后那一次它会搞砸，然后我们就会被取消。
We will definitely get canceled before 30 years from now. Yes, I was going to say we'll link to whoever we do bring on from KX. Phineas will be on. I mean, he's already been on ADSP now. He'll be on ArrayCast at some point. How does it get into array programming language? Oh yeah, great question. So Bryce just asked how did you get into array programming
我们肯定会在 30 年后被取消。是的，我本来要说我们会链接到我们从 KX 邀请的任何人。Phineas 会上。我的意思是，他现在已经上过 ADSP 了。他迟早会上 ArrayCast。它是怎么进入数组编程语言的？哦，对了，好问题。所以 Bryce 刚才问你是怎么进入数组编程的
and specifically actually you don't actually use Q on your day job. You used to use Q. Last time I checked you were using Scala. But anyways, yeah. Give us a little story of how you came to be a Q god. Because he is a Q god. I don't know about a god, but the way
而且特别实际上你并没有在日常工作中真正使用 Q。你过去使用 Q。上次我检查时你在使用 Scala。但总之，是的。给我们讲讲你是怎么成为 Q 之神的故事。因为他是 Q 之神。我不知道是不是神，但方式
I got into Q is a queue god. I don't know about a god, but the way I got into queue was actually quite simple. I was working on a problem which is a little bit related to the classic programming problem, which is suppose I want to know the highest floor I can drop an egg off of, and I have two eggs. And so there's like a canonical solution to this problem. But I was thinking, what if the cost of testing
我进入 Q 是一个 Q 之神。我不知道是不是神，但进入 Q 的方式实际上很简单。我当时正在处理一个问题，这与经典的编程问题有点相关，即假设我想知道我可以从哪一层楼扔鸡蛋，我有两个鸡蛋。所以这个问题有一个规范的解决方案。但我当时在想，如果测试的成本
is not exactly like, you don't have two eggs, but really think about it as the cost is proportional to your guesses. So if you overshoot, you pay some cost proportional to the error. And the way this is, the interesting case for this, that's most interesting, is drug dosing. I want to find the right dosage of a particular drug,
不完全像，你没有两个鸡蛋，但真正把它想成成本与你的猜测成正比。所以如果你过度猜测，你会支付一些与错误成正比的成本。而这，最有趣的情况，是药物剂量。我想找到特定药物的正确剂量，
and I need to know how much your titration. The way that doctors do this is really stupid. They go really slowly up from zero because they don't want to hurt you. But you're obviously getting harmed by not having the right drug the entire way through. So what you should be doing is doing binary search. But obviously, you can't just do binary search and give the guy a lethal dose of the drug and kill them.
我需要知道你的滴定法。医生这样做的方式真的很愚蠢。他们从零开始非常缓慢地增加，因为他们不想伤害你。但你显然因为一直没有得到正确的药物而受到伤害。所以你应该做的是进行二分搜索。但显然，你不能只是做二分搜索，给那个人致命剂量的药物并杀死他们。
So the idea is you need to find some optimal algorithm. It's a skewed binary search. It's a skewed binary search. So I went to go and create a grid search over this whole thing. And I started writing my code in Python. And I had heard that Q was this amazing really fast programming language. And I learned enough Q to implement the language and have the solution finish before my Python code
所以想法是你需要找到一些最优算法。这是一个倾斜的二分搜索。这是一个倾斜的二分搜索。所以我去为整个事情创建了一个网格搜索。我开始用 Python 写代码。我听说 Q 是一门非常棒、非常快的编程语言。我学了足够的 Q 来实现该语言，并在我的 Python 代码之前完成了解决方案
finished running. And I was like, okay, I'm hooked. Oh, wait, so it was running in Python. It was still running in Python. And then you learned enough and coded up, and then it was done while your Python solution was still running. Damn. Also, Python was really slow back then. This is like Python 2.7.
运行结束。我就想，好吧，我上钩了。哦，等等，它在 Python 中运行。它还在 Python 中运行。然后你学了足够多并编码，然后它完成了，而你的 Python 解决方案还在运行。该死。而且 Python 当时真的很慢。这是像 Python 2.7。
You know what? Python is still very slow. They got the Shannon plan, though. For those that know, they know. If you know, you know. Bryce doesn't. What is the canonical solution to the two eggs? You gotta have the mic.
你知道吗？Python 仍然非常慢。不过他们有 Shannon 计划。对于那些知道的人，他们知道。如果你知道，你就知道。Bryce 不知道。两个鸡蛋的规范解决方案是什么？你得有麦克风。
What is the canonical solution to the two eggs? You've got to have the mic. What is the canonical solution to the two eggs problem? You basically exponentially go up the floor. So you go, start from the first floor, then go to two, go to four, go all the way up until the first egg drops, and then go back to the first floor that the egg didn't drop and then
两个鸡蛋的规范解决方案是什么？你得有麦克风。两个鸡蛋问题的规范解决方案是什么？你基本上是指数级地增加楼层。所以你走，从第一层开始，然后去二，去四，一直往上走，直到第一个鸡蛋掉落，然后回到鸡蛋没掉落的第一层，然后
just walk up one floor at a time until both eggs are gone. I mean, you can see why that would not be very welcome to hospitals. You have, like, two patients are dead now. Start with one barely living patient. And for the record, I mean, are the doctors worried about hurting patients or are they just worried about getting sued? Do we really know? We don't know.
只是每次走上一层楼，直到两个鸡蛋都没了。我的意思是，你可以看出为什么这在医院里不会很受欢迎。你有，像，两个病人现在死了。从一个几乎活着的病人开始。顺便说一句，我的意思是，医生是担心伤害病人，还是他们只是担心被起诉？我们真的知道吗？我们不知道。
I didn't understand the better solution to this. hurting patients or are they just worried about getting sued? Do we really know? We don't know. I didn't understand the better solution to this, to the dosing problem. What's the better solution? I wasn't clear on that. The better solution is depending on the cost of overshooting, and it's going to vary, but you can think of it as proportional to the error
我不明白这个问题的更好解决方案。伤害病人还是他们只是担心被起诉？我们真的知道吗？我们不知道。我不明白这个问题的更好解决方案，剂量问题。什么是更好的解决方案？我不清楚。更好的解决方案取决于过度猜测的成本，它会变化，但你可以把它想成与错误成正比
that you overdose by. By proportional, I mean it might be some function of the error between the true value. Suppose you're supposed to give that patient 10 milligrams of something, and you give them 15. That 5 is the error, and some function of 5 is the issue. And it might be some crazy function
你过量了。所谓成正比，我的意思是它可能是真实值之间误差的某个函数。假设你应该给那个病人 10 毫克的东西，而你给了他们 15 毫克。那 5 就是误差，5 的某个函数就是问题所在。它可能是一些疯狂的函数
where it's exponential, right? The idea is that cost is going to be factored into your binary search so that instead of picking the absolute median between the two values you're looking at, you're going to pick a quarter and go to 25% or 10% and so on. But for something like overriding somebody, isn't there a step function to that cost because there's the step function of they're alive versus they're dead yeah so the the way that you could probably you approximate this is basically with some like yeah with some exponential you you can approximate it
它是指数级的，对吧？想法是那个成本将被纳入你的二分搜索中，这样你就不是在寻找的两个值之间选择绝对中位数，而是选择四分之一并去 25% 或 10% 等等。但对于像覆盖某人这样的事情，那个成本没有阶跃函数吗，因为有他们活着与他们死亡的阶跃函数，是的，所以你可以近似这个的方式基本上是带有一些，是的，带有一些指数，你可以近似它
with some exponential cost function so basically like as the error grows larger you just like it goes to your cost cost goes effectively to infinity. But that's kind of how you model it. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
带有一些指数成本函数，所以基本上就像随着误差变大，你只是像它走向你的成本，成本有效地走向无穷大。但这正是你建模它的方式。请务必在你的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目说明，以获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高质量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。